diese sternleiche es wirklich ein
riesiges rätsel für astronomie teams
weltweit in einer entfernung von nur 150
jahren haben fachleute einen weißen
zwerg mit äußerst bizarrem eigenschaften
entdeckt als er und masse passen nicht
zusammen und auch seine entstehung kann
nur durch ein wahrlich gigantisches
szenario erklärt werden klicks um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
white dorfs also weiße zwerge bilden
sich am ende der entwicklung von sternen
es sind also sternleichen auch wenn sie
etwa so groß sind wie die erde
vereinigen sie eine gesamte sonnenmasse
in sich anfangs beträgt ihre
oberflächentemperatur irgendwas zwischen
10.000 grad celsius und achtung 100 1000
grad celsius doch weil sie über keine
zusätzliche energiequelle mehr verfügen
können sie langsam aus und enden als
schwarze zwergen dieser prozess läuft
innerhalb von vielen milliarden jahren
hat eine super spannende sache also die
für astronomie teams aber an sich nichts
ungewöhnliches ist anders aber bei dem
weißen zwerg mit der bezeichnung unten
eingeblendet der etwa 150 lichtjahre von
der erde entfernt ist aufgespürt wurde
die kompakte kugel mit hilfe des
satelliten gaia und schnell war klar
dass es sich um ein ganz besonders
bizarres exemplar handelt und zwar in
vielerlei hinsicht zum einen ist es die
masse die aus dem rahmen fällt denn der
nun aufgespürte weiße zwerg ist rund
1,14 sonnenmassen schwer und somit fast
doppelt so schwer wie viele andere
vertreter seiner art zudem bewegt er
sich mit einer geschwindigkeit von 120
kilometern pro sekunde
viel schneller als andere weiße zwerge
in seinem alter durch die milchstraße
das könnte möglicherweise ein hinweis
darauf sein dass hat doch älter ist als
seine temperatur nahe liegt doch nicht
nur das auch seine zusammensetzung ist
äußerst rätselhaft sein spektrum
entspricht in sachen wasserstoff der
üblichen signatur der stern gleichen
doch anders als die anderen bislang
bekannten weißen zwerge ist der nicht
von einer dünnen heli umschichtung geben
stattdessen wird er von kohlenstoff
wasserstoff um bild das forschungsteam
fasst es so zusammen aber zusätzlich
besitzt er zahlreiche absorptions linien
von atomarem kohlenstoff das macht wie j
0 55
1 4135 zum ersten weißen zwerg mit
dieser spektralen klasse eine
kombination aus wasserstoff und
kohlenstoff ist unerwartet denn zwischen
beiden müsste eine dicke schicht helium
sein die diese mischung verhindert die
forschenden stehen vor einem großen
rätsel denn das hat man so tatsächlich
noch nie gesehen dabei ist der
entstehungsprozess weißer zwerg
eigentlich gut erforscht doch solch ein
resultat ist damit einfach nicht zu
erklären dazu heißt es in der aktuellen
studie wir haben eine zusammensetzung
die wir mit normaler stelara evolution
nicht erklären können eine doppelt so
hohe masse wie üblich und noch dazu ein
kinematische alter das nicht mit der
abkühlung rate übereinstimmt das alles
kann nach ansicht der fachleute nur mit
einem äußerst ungewöhnlichen
entstehungsprozess erklärt werden
möglicherweise haben sich zwei sterne
zunächst in einem äußerst weiten abstand
umrundet und sind dann nach und nach
jeweils zu roten riesen angewachsen dann
erfolgte wohl der kollaps zu weißen
zwergen die sich daraufhin stück für
stück angenähert haben dann kam es final
zu einer verschmelzung dieses
außergewöhnliche szenario erklärt nicht
nur die hohe geschwindigkeit denn alte
sterne bewegen sich eher schneller als
die jüngeren auch die große masse des
weißen zwergs ist somit nachvollziehbar
ebenso das fehlende helium in seiner
außenhülle den simulationen der
fachleute könnte diese bizarre
eigenschaft nämlich darauf
zurückzuführen sein dass das helium im
laufe der zeit ins innere der
sternleiche gesichert ist das alles
würde auch bedeuten dass unten
eingeblendet wirklich sehr alt ist zudem
ist ihm wohl eine supernova nur gerade
so erspart geblieben denn die
schwerkraft eines sterns wird ab einer
masse von rund 1,4 sonnenmassen zu groß
und der kollaps am ende eines brands
zyklus ist die folge weitere analysen
sollen jetzt zeigen ob die sternen
leichen tatsächlich aus zwei
verschmolzen weißen zwergen entstanden
ist diese sterne sind plötzlich
verschwunden wie ist das möglich
anklicken anschauen und neugier zone
abonnieren bis dann daran unbedingt
cooles video kanal hammer